nouvel objectif vacances avec la croatie
qui attire à nouveau de nombreux
touristes notamment des français qui
aiment retrouver le caractère un peu
rétro et aussi tendance de ce pays des
balkans avec aussi des agences
immobilières qui propose de vendre des
îles en mer adriatique véritable bijou
dont certaines sont mises sur le marché
pour trois millions de dollars reportage
il mariné et à la location entre route
et précipices sur la corniche c'est là
qu'il faut prendre le cliché
incontournable dubrovnik et sa citadelle
envahi par des touristes de plus en plus
tricolore invasion amicale des français
cette année
ivo sait de quoi il parle les
interprètes sont débordés des français
de toute génération découvre les visages
de la croatie émission télé qui vous ont
vanté la croatie qui on a eu le coup de
foudre on historique et branché il fait
beau la mairie si mes histoires et les
îles magnifiques lui rend chez et un
brin inquiet de manger il ya quelques
jours la princesse caroline de monaco
après le frisson people la moiteur de
l'ascension sous un soleil implacable
plus de 30 degrés les remparts de
dubrovnik se mérite
la photo là encore est obligatoire mme
en voyant ça on pardonne beaucoup aux
escaliers
les touristes sont nombreux les
restaurateurs aussi autour de la proie
c'est la foire d'empoigné une table vaut
de l'or en quelques années le prix du
mètre carré a connu une progression
fulgurante la ville là où c'est le plus
cher le prix du mètre carré peut
atteindre 5 à 6000 euros et renault à
quelques kilomètres de là et toujours
avec ivo on ne parle plus en fut-il m²
pas de détails ici c'est la vente en
gros une île sinon rien trois millions
et demi de dollars le prix de ce paradis
tout proche de dubrovnik confisqués par
l'état communiste restituée au
propriétaire à la chute du régime
une vingtaine d'îles sont ainsi à vendre
en l'état actuel la loi crois tu que
retarder la transaction pas l'empêcher
au grand dam de niveau s'est il un passé
religieux elle fait aussi lieu
d'exécution d'opposants au régime
communiste chargé de l'histoire
culturelle religieux et aussi les
sauniers des familles qui ont elles
disent les siennes sur cette île et les
eaux sont ici dans le robot et demain
ivo devra retourner dans le chaudron de
la citadelle les vagues de touristes ne
laisse pas de répit
sinon chaque soir celui ci